good morning believe nation today's
message is be prepared to handle
anything over to you Muhammad Ali you
know I'm sure Henry Italian and fighter
and the knows what's happening
you really can't plan to fight it when
you meet the man you've never met before
right you just have to get your tools
ready here's a car stops on the highway
they call a triple-a or whatever and
said my car's broke down what is it lady
she don't know us but well the man comes
with all the tools and he come equipped
to handle whatever the problem is i
astronaut goes into space and he
pretends that something happens to just
ship before you take off he gets out and
he works on it he's not looking for
something happen but it might happen so
I didn't I just had everything ready now
after the first round being here with a
top professional a man so great had sold
me the Knockouts and never been defeated
never even scratched I didn't know
really how good he was so I had to come
in actually a little nervous and with
everything ready after one round of
deaths and I found out that this would
tire me out so I would have to resort to
ropes I'll figure that out after the
first round this is a message that I
think entrepreneurs can definitely
relate to because we are faced with all
sorts of odds that are thrown against us
that we never anticipated and any plan
that you make as an entrepreneur you're
gonna make mistakes your first business
plan you think you've got the greatest
plan in the world and you put it out and
you realize that it was completely wrong
and the real measure of an entrepreneur
is gonna be how you react how quickly
you can react to all those things that
do go wrong that you weren't ready for
but you can quickly get back on track
and continue to build your business and
my first company spent an entire summer
making a business plan one that I
thought I had researched so well and it
was perfect and of course it was gonna
work and I had success in everything
else that I did and this was my
opportunity finally after an entire
summer spent day in day at work on this
business plan we're finally ready to
and it turned out that our customers
didn't actually care about a lot of the
things that we were doing that a lot of
our assumptions were wrong and that
could have killed our company but we
reacted quickly we encounter punched we
saw what the market was giving us and we
made adjustments to make sure that we
could have success with our company so
if it doesn't work out the first time
don't freak out don't panic you will get
punched down you will get knocked to the
mat and it's the entrepreneurs who get
back up who make adjustments who figure
out a new way to stand and make their
business be successful those are the
entrepreneurs who stand up so my
question of the day today is what's the
single biggest adjustment you've had to
make in your business from when you
started to where you are now that you've
had to change around leave in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso